欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一小节我们来讲一下关于店铺定位, 让巡盘来得更加精准
店铺的一切操作都要朝着一个目标方向去努力, 才能够实现资源正向积累, 才能够达到一个爆发的点
你会发现很多人他运营一个店铺, 效果都是反馈, 频频都是这样波动的
因为他没有按照一个逻辑去做正向的积累, 没有这种突破性的流量
所以我们一定要把店铺定位精准的就朝着这个方向去努力, 才能实现资源的正向积累, 才更容易达到一个流量的爆发点
那么接下来我们就来详细讲解一下关于定位怎么样去做
首先我们这个定位分为几个板块
第一个我们来讲一下为什么要定位
因为定位好了
那么我们的店铺就能够形成一个差异化的打法
找到了自己的方向跟目标
第二个就是店铺定位好了
那么对于我们后期的人群属性地域属性客户类型等等
都会直接影响到我们的寻盘质量
寻盘质量的高低也就直接决定着我们开发的订单的多与少
就是成交的容易程度
第三个就是如果定位好了
后期我们的直通车策略就会不一样
直接决定着你怎么样去操作直通车
那么第四个就是如果你把店铺定位做好了
那么你就能够保持店铺的运营方向跟公司的目标是一致的
才能够充分发挥我们公司的资源优势
在运营跟业务充分的协作下
快速的拿到结果
这是我们最想要的结果
总的来说呢
店铺定位好了
就是在正确的方向上
用正确的方法去实现店铺的运营目标
持续的做正向积累
那么到底怎么样去做呢
首先第一个定位的方向就是行业定位
行业定位的话
你首先要选对你所要做的行业
这个行业你一定要选对
因为整个店铺
他每年只能更换两次主营类幕
而且你每次更换主营类幕
就是会直接影响到原始的店铺效果和数据的
相当于从头开始
所以说一定要明确好你的行业
第二个就是
内幕的话不要随意的修改
因为这个修改就会直接影响到你的人群
国家的精准度以及店铺的权重
第三个为什么要强调一定要明确好你的行业
因为不同的主营以及内幕在平台的竞争度和平台的权重是不一样的
比如说你选的服装行业跟香包或者是机械行业
这些行业里面的竞争度都是不一样的
所包含的词也是不一样的
所以一定要明确好这个行业
第四如果换品了
就建议在同一个主营类幕下换其他的产品
比如说你做的是服装类幕
那么你就在服装类幕下去增加产品或更换这些产品就可以了
不要跨度太大
跨度太大的话人群国家都偏离了
这些的话都会对你店铺的转化有影响的
所以我们一定要提前了解行业现状跟趋势
多关注一些平台的资讯跟方向
或者是说行业的一些情况再去做选择
一定要明确店铺选择哪个行业
有些工厂类型的他们可能就已经很明确了
但是有些贸易公司的可能就需要自己去选择更加准确的行业
因为这个是直接决定的我们后期流量的大小
也就是流量的天花板
以及跟同行的竞争程度
或者是整个市场对这些产品的需求度
都会在你选择行业的时候
就大致已经被确定了这些方向
所以一定要慎重的去选对行业
接下来的第三个呢
就是我们的产品定位
因为我们的产品是不是会有很多很多种品类
那么我们要怎么样去选择合适的产品
在店铺上去做呢
首先第一个就是我们一定要明确我们的主打产品
产品的风格功能找到市场存在需求
客户群体足够大的市场
然后快速切入这个市场
如果你是工厂类型的
可能你就有了自己的产品
自己的产品可能就是主推
而你如果是贸易类型的公司
可能要去选品
那么选品就可以参考这些去选就可以了
多维度去选择
因为行业你确定了之后就到产品
产品的话你就按照这种思路去选
选好了产品之后
你会有很多产品线
那么你要在店铺里面明确你的核心的产品是哪些
比如说你选了15个产品线
那么15个产品线里面你还要挑选出1到5个
或者是1到3个
你非常核心去主打的
因为这些主打的产品
后期可能会涉及到自动车
问顶顶厂等等资源的配合
以及会涉及到哪些产品是我业务转化更好
或者是我公司供应链更有优势的产品
所以说这些都要考虑清楚
以及到后期会决定着我们的池根要明确
到时候要覆盖更多的关键词
第三个就是产品优势和同行有什么不同
我们在选定了产品之后
我们又要去做我们的优势分析
以及我们的价格
NOQ功能材质等等
从这些细分的维度去分析我们的产品
第四个就是去看我们的关键词搜索指数的竞争程度如何
去判断这一类产品能不能快速的去做起来
比如说你去做一些比较冷门的
那么可能难度就比较大
你通过去看关键词的搜索指数就可以知道了
还有第五个就不讲了
刚才我们已经讲了
第六个也是一样的
这些都需要我们去明确好
因为这些都会决定着我们后期的各种运营动作是否有效的一个前提
通过这个产品定位好了之后
我们就能够得出引流产品是哪种
活动产品是哪种
利润产品
还有主推产品
分别是什么
这些都会非常明确
接下来就是我们所讲的一个人群定位
人群定位的话
我们要非常清楚的知道上面的这些产品
是卖给哪类人群
这样的话
才能够让我们的产品更加精准比配到给需求的人群
才更容易得到转化和订单的成交
所以这些一定要先去了解你这些产品的客户群体到底哪些你要去了解这些
第二个就是
他们这些人都有哪些共同的属性
比如说他对价格啊款式风格
NOQ的接受程度大概范围是在哪些地方
而且我们能不能做得到的
你要去分析这些
第三个就是我们的
样品呢还有就是
功能啊这些是不是比较符合这一类人群的需求
因为只有需求才能够
让客户买单
你把这些产品
卖给没有需求的人是很难
把这产品销售出去的
所以
这个一定要非常明确你的目标人群
第四个的话我们如果不知道这些人群有哪些痛点
或者是有哪些需求的话
我们可以去亚马逊的评论
或者是业务跟
客户平时沟通
总结得到的一些他们的需求
或者是我们可以在国际上同行看同类产品的评价
看看客户
都在关心哪些问题
通过这些去收集客户的需求和客户的痛点
我们在
万户首页装修
详情页设计
的时候
就把那些客户
重点关注的问题呈现出来
并且提供有效的解决方案
就更加能够吸引我们的客户去发寻盘和
转化订单
最后面
在自动的推广的时候
还有业务洽谈的时候
我们都能够非常明确
我们要推给哪一类人群
所以说这都是非常明确的一个方向去做
每一件事情的
人群定位好了之后
我们还要锁定
我们的目标国家
也就是这些人
虽然说有需求
但是能不能接受我们的产品的这些价格起定量
都是和这个国家有着非常
重要的关系的
比如说你的一款产品
是比较贵的产品
如果是你卖给美国
它的价格是很容易得到接受的
但是如果是你卖给东南亚
或者是卖给非洲的国家
那么他们的接受度
是比较低的
即使他们这些比较落后的国家能够接受这些价格
但是他里面的人是很少的
所以说我们想要在这些人少的国家去捞这些优质的客户
概率是很小的
所以说我们一定要去做能够成功概率更大的事情
第一个就是我们要明确我们的主营国家有哪些需求旺盛的国家
就是这些这样的话我们就能够大概率的获得更多的流量
第二个就是这些国家他们的风格偏好是什么
物流啊时效啊清光这些他们的偏好到底是什么样的
因为不同的国家他们的清光的手续还有就是物流的时效还有价格都是不一样的
所以说这些一定要去了解清楚
第三个就是线下过往你成交过哪些
哪些国家是最好成交的
我们就要把这些国家锁定
比如说我们是有做过外贸的
那么之前做的这些品类
成交的国家都很明确
而且是很容易成交的
那么我们在做国际站店铺的时候
就马上开始主打这些国家
也就是在已经被验证过的市场上面去
努力获取这些客户
才能够最快的达成我们的目的
第四个就是你可以看一下过往巡盘最多的国家都有哪些
这些国家的转化率高不高
就选择这些国家去作为你的主打国家
第五个就是主打国家的产品竞争度
市场容量是否足够大
是否存在增量
这些我们可以在库台的市场分析里面就看到因为我们如果是去做了一个市场
他容量不大
或者是说他的增速不快
那么我们对于流量的
增长就很慢
同时呢我们可能成交的
订单的天花板
有限
很快就峰顶了
很难增长了
所以说一定要去判断这个
市场的容量是否足够大
是否存在增量
这些都非常重要
接下来的话这两个板块就是关于
直通车的为什么
一定要定位好
国家
因为直通车推广的时候能够锁定
核心的国家的时候
那么就能够提升我们整体的
推广的价值
就直接会影响到我们后期
巡盘的精准度和转化效果
比如说我们如果把产品推广到了非主营的目标国家
转化率是会很低的
转化率很低就导致你的
直通车的推广成本上涨
推广成本上涨是不是你的整体的
公司的运营成本就会上升了
所以这个是非常关键的一个推广的策略
第四个就是
国家的标签的沉淀
比如说我们之前也讲过
店铺有国家标签
产品也有国家标签
如果我们的国家标签不精准
那么后期系统给我们推荐的流量还有
系统推荐的自然流量
都是不够精准的
如果这种不精准的情况下
就会导致我们的转化率低
转化率低
也就导致了我们店铺在后期可能会持续的低转化
这会浪费我们大量的
运营时间
所以一定要重视起来
这个国家定位
最后一个呢就是我们
的店铺类型的定位
你要知道
我们现在平台上
是有很多种店铺类型的
有做现货的
有做
纯定制的
品牌的
所以说一定要提前规划
你店铺要走到哪个方向
你店铺的
类型不一样
产品
所发的类型不一样
都会决定着你流量
大小不一样
第一个
比如说以定制为主的店铺
他是会在产品详情页
上面做一些差异的
他会把产品跟商家同时展示
更注重于生产能力和公司的实力的
那么推广策略方面呢
主推一些
定制的产品
同时绑定信保订单的时候也是以定制的产品绑定为主
定制的店铺主要是以循环为主开始
然后加订单的服务
这是跟RTS是不一样的
我们来看一下RTS店铺
RTS的店铺的话是以订单为主的
那么他的
涨势的优势主要是各种
热销款式
因为很多做RTS的
卖家主要就是卖一些畅销款
他更注重于就是买家订单的严肃跟评价
还有就是购买的
地区是哪些
这样会决定你的一个
销量跟你的一个利润
所以说一定要重视这个
板块
你如果是用RTS店铺去做的话那么你一定要
重视下面这些
访单跟场景流量一定要重视起来
如果你是做
一键代发的话那么你就按照这个标准去做就可以了
因为一键代发的话现在已经被诱化了
之前是红利期所以说
很多人
通过一键代发拿到了结果
最后面我们来讲一些关于店铺类型定位的重要的
一些判断标准和一些倾斜的资源
第一个如果我们做定制店铺的时候
我们一定要想办法
让我们的店铺里面的产品是定制
产品比RTS产品是在7:3
如果你是RTS店铺的话那么就反过来
通过产品数来进行一个
划分这个店铺是定制还是
是RTS
那么运营的时候我们也要侧重某一个方向
不能两个方向都在同时
发力
这样的话就导致你店铺定位不精准
平台不知道你的店铺到底是往哪个方向去匹配人群的
所以一定要侧重一个方向
持续的积累资源在某一个方向上面
那么如果你是定制店铺那么你定制的新等级一定要高于RTS的新等级
如果你做RTS
店铺那么就反过来操作就可以了
因为定制店铺跟RTS店铺他们的流量入口
是非常多样化的
它不同的产品在不同的板块引流
我们上次也讲了国家首页是不是有两个端口
那么你不同的产品就会在不同的流量板块
那么下面很多板块也是不同的产品类型
比如说RTS
或者是定制产品
他能够在的板块是不一样的
所以说
一定要把
店铺规划好
同时把产品
数量规划好
这样的话
因为你获得流量是从这几个局道进来的
他会不一样的
所以一定要重视起来
还有这些什么促销活动私欲
有些东西定制是不能报名的
只有RTS产品可以报名
最后一个就是店铺权重的判断
也就是
平台会根据我们店铺
和新产品数量最多的二级类目作为星级的类目评估
这个是
以数量作为判断的
所以说我这里为什么要强调你的数量占比以及你的一个品类的选择
第二个就是交易量决定店铺的星级系统匹配的客户
层级和质量都是不一样的
比如说我们之前讲的星级
0星1星
2星3星4星5星
每一个星级分配的流量是不一样的
而且它匹配的买家的质量
也是有一定的差异的
但是不是绝对的差异
第三个就是交易人群类型
如果我们店铺主营定制产品
那么如果我们推广的时候
总是去推广RTS产品
那么这个就会导致我们店铺的精准度出现问题
寻盘的质量出现问题
所以说一定要重视这个板块的区分
那么下面这个就自己看了
总体上来说我们的店铺定位
就主要分为这几个板块进行一个定位
那么我们在进行定位的时候如果你不清楚怎么样去做
那么你直接就参考着这个思路按照步骤一个个去明确
并且把它写出来
写到你的文档或者是表格中
明确好这些作为我们目标的分解
作为我们每月每周运营方向的一个指南针
这样的话我们的所有的动作
都是在围绕着这些目标去进行努力的
所以当你把店铺定位好了
按照这个思路去做
那么你的店铺就能够持续的积累数据
能够快速的做起来
所以
这是非常重要的一种店铺运营的思路
如果你现在店铺还没有定位好
那么可以重新按照这个方法去定位
然后再开始重新规划你的运营的方向和
具体的运营方法再去执行
那么你一定能够
更快的拿到结果
接下来我们话不多说就开始行动吧
我们这节课就先讲到这里
下节课再见